نبدا بملفنا الاول وهو الاكثر تفاعلا اذ
عقدت الحكومه الاسرائيليه جلستها
الاسبوعيه داخل نفق اسفل الناحيه الغربيه
من المسجد الاقصى احتفاءا بالذكرى السادسه
والخمسين لاحتلال القدس وتنوي حكومه
نتنياهو التصديق على سلسله من القرارات
والمشاريع بهدف تشجيع الشبان اليهود على
الانتقال للعيش في القدس وقد صدقت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على اضافه نحو 17 مليون دولار
لميزانيه حفر الانفاق تحت حائط البراق
والبلده القديمه وفي مستهل جلسه الحكومه
الاسبوعيه هذه قال رئيس الوزراء بن يمين
نتانياهو ان اسرائيل وحدت مدينه القدس بعد
الحرب قبل 56 عاما لكن معركه توحيدها ما
تزال مستمره بحسب تعبيره
قبل 56 عاما خلال حرب الايام السته وحدنا
القدس لكنني مضطر للقول ان المعركه على
توحيدها لم تكتمل لانني وزملائم مضطرون
مره تلو الاخرى الى صد الضغوط الدوليه من
قبل اولئك الذين يريدون اعاده تقسيم القدس
وايضا من قبل رؤساء حكومات في اسرائيل
كانوا مستعدين للاستسلام لهذه الضغوط
لدرجه انهم كانوا مستعدين للتنازل عن
الاماكن الاكثر قدسيه لليه